[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIM BRAY: Hey there.
I'm Tim Bray, and this
is Breno de Medeiros.
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: Hi, there.
TIM BRAY: And we are both
in the Identity
Group here at Google.
And we kind of think that
identity is one of the biggest
pain points on the internet.
And Google's all about removing
pain points on the
internet, because we want you
to be online all the time.
So the center of the pain point
is passwords, of course.
And remembering passwords sucks,
and typing in passwords
sucks, and typing in passwords
on mobile devices deeply,
deeply sucks.
And this pain point's been
around for a while, and so
there's been a bunch of
technologies dreamed up by the
industry over the years
to try and solve it.
And most of them have gone
nowhere, but we've been
working on this for a while.
And Google's betting pretty
heavily on a couple of these
technologies.
One of them is called OAuth 2.0,
and there's some other
stuff built on top of that
like OpenID Connect.
And Breno here is the tech
lead of the team that's
actually building
all this stuff.
And he's also got his name
on the front of a
bunch of the specs.
And I don't know how closely you
people have been watching
this stuff, but that process has
ground on for a long time,
and it was really
controversial.
And the editor flounced out of
the room saying everything
sucked, life sucked, the
internet sucked.
And the specs weren't frozen
forever and ever, and yet,
here's Google betting on them.
And they do things like
send bearer tokens in
the open and so on.
So, are we crazy?
Do they really suck?
Is OAuth good enough for Google
to be betting on?
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: OAuth 2.0
has many very good and
flexible features that makes us
think that it's the right
fit for the internet
at this point.
A lot of the criticism
of OAuth 2.0 was
based on two grounds.
There was some criticism on the
basis that the security
was not good enough.
There was some criticism on the
basis that OAuth 2.0 was
too complex.
The complexity argument, I
think, is just unfair.
OAuth 2.0 is essentially
a suite of protocols.
It has a number of specialized
flows.
So if you look at the entire
spec suite, it
looks like a lot.
But typically, you come to OAuth
2.0 trying to solve a
specific problem.
And when you come with that
perspective, OAuth 2.0 has a
simple answer to the problem
you're trying to solve.
And so the complexity argument,
I think, doesn't
hold much water.
On the security argument, we
do have a lot of experience
with addressing hard security
issues and the internet.
And the fact that we're betting
so heavily on OAuth
2.0 means that we are
confident we can
make it work securely.
TIM BRAY: Excellent.
Now, it's been changing
and changing.
Are they finished?
There's still a working group.
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: There is
still a working group.
Essentially, the RFC
is finalized.
TIM BRAY: There's actually
an RFC number now?
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: There
is an RFC number.
And there is still some
extensions that are being
worked on with OAuth 2.0.
I think the most important one
to keep track of is the OpenID
Connect, which is a separate
working group, but it's
designed to be an identity layer
on top of OAuth 2.0.
TIM BRAY: OK.
So we're betting on it.
What are we actually doing?
What do we have in production?
What's out there?
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: So there
are a couple of things out
there from the point
of view of APIs.
Google has been making an
enterprise-wide effort to put
together some--
make our APIs work more
homogeneously and
more easy to use.
And OAuth is a big
part of this.
So we are baking OAuth 2.0
in all of our APIs and
documenting this.
We are getting good feedback
from developers.
TIM BRAY: Well, that's a big
deal, because I've only been
involved in this for a while.
But up until quite recently,
the developer experience on
OAuth was horrible.
It was hard to find good
libraries, and then there were
11 steps, and you had to have
a deep understanding of
cryptography and so on.
And particularly on mobile,
it was no there there.
So how are we doing?
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: Mobile is
one of the places where I
think we have a good start
in OAuth 2.0, really very
different from what
was there before.
The new platform for
authorization in Android has,
essentially, a way to get tokens
based on activities.
So the user experience of
interacting with an
application that was built on
these new platforms is that
the app brings the activity to
let the user choose which
account they want to use
of the application.
And after the user chooses the
account, then they are shown
an approval prompt.
And if they decide to go forward
with it, which the
vast majority of the cases they
said it is the case, and
so then they would be right
back into the application.
And after that, the application
just has to
trigger an activity to obtain
a token and access the user
data from Google APIs with
the user's consent.
TIM BRAY: I wrote one
of those apps.
And it's not all that simple,
because it's not synchronous,
because you might have
to go off the network
to ask for the token.
And you might actually have to
go back to the user to check
for their consent, and so on.
So it's asynchronous, but
it's not terrible.
Another thing we've been working
on that isn't actually
a Google product-- it's an
OpenID Foundation product-- is
this thing called
Account Chooser.
And if you go to my blog at
tbray.org, I did a piece on it
yesterday, I guess.
And I think that's a big deal.
It's not a Google product,
as I said.
It's just a chunk of open-source
JavaScript from
the OpenID Foundation.
And what it is trying to offer
is one-click log in, and even
in some cases one-click
sign up on sites.
So when you go to some site,
you don't see that site's
landing page.
You see just a list of the
accounts you've used to log on
to various other places.
You click one, pop!
You're in.
One click.
It's still just starting to
lurch into life, but I think
it's going to reduce login
friction quite a
bit around the net.
BRENO DE MEDEIROS:
Yeah, and Account
Chooser is a great idea.
It basically addresses the
issue of what we call the
NASCAR problem, which is the
fact that the moment that you
try to accept sign ins from
a different provider--
say Google, Yahoo, Microsoft,
Live, Facebook--
you are presented with the
problem of how to render your
login page.
What are the options they're
going to put there?
So Account Chooser gives you a
simple and clean answer to
that question.
TIM BRAY: Cool.
Let me ask another question.
There's a million Android
developers out there-- well,
not literally, but there's
really a lot of Android
developers out there--
and almost every Android
app has a back end.
And even the most simple game
will have some sort of a back
end to persist and share high
scores or something like that.
And so the guy who's writing the
code for the back end has
a problem, which is, how
do they know who
they're talking to?
I mean, how do they know this
is Joe's high score at
Solitaire as opposed
to Sally's?
And you don't want them to have
to go and log in to your
site again, because they've
already approved
access to the site.
So how do I make that easy for
the back-end developer?
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: So as I
mentioned, we have a number of
different flows that
are designed to
address this issue.
This particular problem is going
to be addressed in the
new release of the Android
authorization,
which is very soon.
And what it allows it to do is
to get a simple, what we call,
an ID token and authentication
token that the phone can get
without any additional consent
except the initial consent to
identify the user.
They can provide, essentially,
a login
token to their website.
And so you don't have to view
the authorization protocol to
authenticate your device back
to the home server.
TIM BRAY: Excellent.
So stand by and watch
for that.
OK, so I think we've talked
enough, and let's see what
people want to talk to us.
Now I see we've got some
questions on the moderator,
and I understand there may be
some coming in over YouTube.
So let me sort those.
So I'm going to skip the first
question, because it isn't
really about identity.
OK, our thoughts on Mozilla's
Persona Project.
It looks promising, simple
for users and developers,
decentralized, and based
on pragmatic choices.
And actually, they left
out one thing.
The people who are promoting
Persona are making very strong
claims about privacy,
the fact that logins
won't be logged anywhere.
So it looks very promising.
It's kind of complicated.
I'm pretty sure that the
ecosystem of identity
providers is going to
be complicated.
It's going to be
multi-provider,
multi-protocol.
I wouldn't be surprised at all
if Persona was one of the
protocols in there.
And if it's hard to hook Account
Chooser up to it, then
that's a bug in Account
Chooser.
The one issue I had with Persona
that I haven't been
able to get a straight answer on
yet is, what's the story on
mobile devices?
Because anything you're going to
do on identity these days,
if it doesn't have a good answer
for mobile device app
programmers, it's just
not very interesting.
But Persona looks like
a good effort.
We talk to them on a regular
basis and good for them.
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: And there is
an interesting overlap, I
believe, between Persona and
Account Chooser where Account
Chooser also has many
interesting privacy features.
The settings are stored only
locally on your client.
On the other hand, it has a
very simple JavaScript on
interface that means that it
works in every browser
essentially, including
mobile platforms.
And so there is some
possibility, for instance, for
clients to extend
[? the behavior of ?]
Account Chooser.
We think there's a possibility
for these
efforts to converge further.
TIM BRAY: That's right.
In fact, we've had some informal
talk about browser
builders building Account
Chooser right into the browser
and I would hope that would snap
on to things like Persona
very nicely.
OK.
MALE SPEAKER: There's one
question on YouTube I wanted
to address, Tim and Breno.
One of the conversations
is about authorization.
And when you give authorization
to your
identity, often they ask for
nonessential details--
for example, your photos.
So if you're trying to share a
high score for a game, they
also ask for permission
to your photos.
How do you address kind of
that granular permissions
issue that's available there?
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: So our API
authorizations have a concept
of scope, which is actually also
a concept of the OAuth
2.0 protocol.
And what it means is that a
developer that wants to use
OAuth 2.0 with Google, they will
typically target one or
more of the Google APIs.
And when they look at the
documentation of the APIs,
they'll find out what scopes
they need to use--
they need to request to have
access to that type of data.
And the consent page, you have
a single consent page that
will disclose to the user
everything that the app is
requesting access to.
TIM BRAY: I notice in OpenID
Connect, they thought about
that a lot.
If you look at OpenID Connect,
they've got some very, very
well-defined scopes.
So when you want to go through
that protocol and establish
identity, you can say, all I
care about is the email.
Here's this email.
Is this person actually logged
into that email, yes or no?
Or you can actually
ask for more.
You can say email, profile.
And the definition
of profile varies
from provider to provider.
For example, I noticed that
Google has a picture of it,
but Microsoft Live doesn't
last time I looked.
And the selection of information
that comes out
varies from provider provider.
First of all, the app that's
using this can ask for the
minimum and, in many
cases, they should.
And the second important thing
is, as far as I know, you
always get told what's
going to be given up.
The scope string always--
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: Right.
TIM BRAY: --there's an approval
screen saying, this
app is asking for this data.
And if you get a surprise, you
find that it's given more than
you thought you were giving
access to, that's a bug and
something that you should
complain about.
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: Right.
And even though, as Tim
mentioned, what is actually in
the profile of the user changes
depending on which
provider you were targeting,
there is an expectation about
a set of fields that are
supposed to be commonly found.
And there is a standard
way to refer to those.
So you can at least reuse some
of that parsing effort.
TIM BRAY: OK.
Let's go back to the moderator
for a moment here.
Here's one I particularly
like.
How can relying parties be
certain of the veracity of
identity providers?
If I say I'm me, is that good
enough for some access levels
and not others?
Should government banks,
VeriSign, or someone else be
trusted to vouch for our
online identity?
Well, that's more of a
policy question than
a technology question.
Now, do bear in mind that all
of these identity protocols
work over HTTPS, so you can at
least be sure that you are
talking to a real identity
provider.
You really are talking
to Google or
your bank or whoever.
And beyond that, you really
enter the universe of trust.
I mean, would you rather trust
Facebook or Google or your
bank or your VeriSign
or your university?
That's a question of
real-world policy.
The thing, though, is that for
many people who want to offer
websites, the business of
running a login password
system and storing passwords and
avoiding being hacked is
so onerous and so painful and
so expensive that there's a
real strong desire to get out of
that business and into the
mode of using identity
providers.
So I think that people are going
to want to start using
identity providers.
And that means that it's really,
I think, the task of
the identity providers to earn
your trust and keep it.
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: Exactly.
The protocols do take on the
task of explaining how you can
identify the provider in
a trustworthy manner.
But how much trust you place
in the provider is
really up to you.
TIM BRAY: Right.
So App Engine and the recently
announced Cloud Endpoints
still in closed beta
I'm afraid?
Yes, but I think they're
getting close.
Support OAuth and Play Services
have greatly improved
OAuth on Android.
Actually, they made
it possible.
It really wasn't before.
So what's the new recommended
way of putting all these
pieces together?
Any good examples?
Well the best example, I think,
is the libraries that
we provide.
We provide pre-cooked libraries
in Java and Ruby for
using all this stuff.
And they just make
all that go away.
You say, here's the API I want
to access, here's who I am,
and it goes away and does
all the OAuth dance.
And that's also going to be work
for the Cloud Endpoints
in the App Engine case.
So if you can use those,
that's a good idea.
I, myself, tend to like building
at a lower level and
actually using the RESTful
endpoints, which means I need
to actually do the OAuth
dance and get tokens
and put tokens on.
But even at that painful level,
it's not that painful.
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: Yeah.
Tim showed us how to whip up one
of these apps in a pinch.
TIM BRAY: Yeah.
We had a bug there earlier this
week, and we built eight
apps in the course of a
day to chase it down.
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: Right.
So I think the Play
Service is--
TIM BRAY: The Play Service is
a big deal for Android.
It makes so many things possible
that weren't before.
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: And sorry,
when I was talking about
Android Auth platform
before I really
meant the Play Services.
TIM BRAY: So what do you think
the future of OAuth is?
Eran Hammer publicly quit--
I wouldn't say publicly, I would
say loudly quit-- as
editor and claiming that the
specification is more complex,
less interoperable, yadda,
yadda, yadda, yadda.
Will there be OAuth 3.0?
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: Oh, god.
Oh well.
So will there be OAuth 3.0?
We certainly hope not.
And are the problems with
interoperability in OAuth 2.0?
Basically, when you're working
with an application in OAuth
2.0, you are targeting APIs
that are typically
provider-specific.
And so what OAuth 2.0 gives
you is a largely reusable
framework where you can
basically write code once and
modify a few bits of
configuration and get another
provider in the bag.
So is that an interoperability
problem, or is it an
interoperability win?
TIM BRAY: I would put
it like this.
So an internet protocol like
HTTP or SMTP or one of those
is truly interoperable.
If you have a server that
plays by the rules and a
client that plays by the rules,
you can plug them in
together, and they just work.
So OAuth 2.0 isn't like that.
OAuth 2.0 is--
you have this great big piece
of machinery that you can
operate and what comes
out of it is a token.
And then you can use the token
to secure your HTTP
conversations.
But it is not the case that if
you write code to use OAuth
2.0 to access Google APIs that
then you can automatically
reuse it for Facebook APIs.
That level of interoperability
isn't there.
I just lost my microphone.
I'll just hold it up
here like this.
I hope that's good enough.
On the other hand, the way I
think of OAuth 2.0 is as a
framework for building
protocols.
So the first example of that
that's being worked on is
OpenID Connect.
And OpenID Connect uses the
OAuth flows to provide
login-like functions.
And I think my bet is that
OpenID Connect really will be
interoperable.
BRENO DE MEDEIROS:
That's right.
TIM BRAY: If you have a client
and a server that play by the
rules, they should be able
to talk to each other
automatically.
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: Right.
And so I think that's the
crucial part of this, that
OAuth gives you lots
of tools, and the
tools are very reusable.
And so once you have
standard API--
and OpenID Connect, for
instance, is trying to provide
a standard identity
API for the web--
you can build interoperable
protocols based on
top of OAuth 2.0.
And I think that's
what's important.
MALE SPEAKER: So one of the
concerns that I often hear
about standards is that
individual companies will make
changes to those standards so
that what you might believe is
something which is working
across all those different
networks, it becomes tied to
a specific silo with one
company's infrastructure.
How can we work to not become
either another silo or to work
with others to make sure that
the sign in that we do on
Google works at these other
networks, also?
TIM BRAY: Right.
So at the OpenID Connect working
group, they're doing a
really smart thing.
They actually have a formal
interoperability framework
where lots of players are
publishing candidate servers
and clients and trying them out
and discovering whether
they work against each other.
And we are actually in the
process of rolling out an
OpenID Connect endpoint that
we are going to claim is
conformant to the spec.
And that I think if anybody has
a client that they claim
is conformant to the spec and
it doesn't interoperate, I
think we'd take that a bug.
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: Right.
TIM BRAY: So yeah, that's
a very reasonable
thing to worry about.
It also has to do with the
nature of the protocol.
Sort of the worst-case example
of all that is SQL.
SQL is famously
non-interoperable.
Just because you have something
that works with
Oracle, the chance that it's
going to automatically work
with a competitor
is very small.
And the reason for that is the
designers of SQL, whenever
they found a choice, are we
going to do it this way or do
it that way, adopted both.
And if you look at the SQL
standard, it's immensely large
in size, and everything
is optional.
And for everything, there's
multiple ways of doing it.
The number of choices you've
cut down on increases your
chances of getting good
interoperability.
And I'm kind of a standards
veteran, and I'm pretty
optimistic about OpenID Connect,
at least, that it
will have real good
interoperability.
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: So trying to
make the choices that will
work with most and allow the
ones that need special
behavior to work on extensions
without compromising the
interoperability baseline.
TIM BRAY: To go back to the
previous question, one of the
things that Eran said was
that OAuth 2.0 was just
insufficiently secure.
I really want to push back
on that a little bit.
Breno, by the way, is a
first-class security expert,
which I'm not.
So I'll let him tell me what
I just said that's wrong.
Security is not a binary
continuum where you're either
secure or you're insecure.
It's a continuous variable.
And I think what we're all
trying to do is hit an 80/20
point where you have stuff that
is secure enough to be
usable by ordinary people and
ordinary developers and is
still good enough.
And my opinion is that OAuth
2.0 bearer tokens exchanged
over TLS modern HTTPS web
connections is good enough for
practical purposes.
Now, certain very high-security
operations may
have extra requirements,
but I think we're at
a good enough level.
Breno, as an expert,
what do you think?
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: So for
instance, I definitely think
that OAuth 2.0 has a better
balance of security with
usability than OAuth 1.0 did.
If you look at the OAuth 1.0
design, there was a lot more
crypto in it.
And I'm not afraid of crypto,
but I know a lot of people who
are, and with good reason.
In particular, the way that
OAuth 1.0 uses crypto is not
fully compatible with how HTTP
works, which makes people's
life a lot harder.
They have to deal with problems
they normally don't
have to deal with in the course
of web development.
And so also, not all benefits
were obtained by using crypto
in OAuth 1.0.
OAuth 1.0 didn't worry too much
about key management, and
so the crypto bits caused more
pain than gain from a security
perspective.
I think a lot of more
experienced folks got involved
in the design of OAuth 2.0 and
a lot of the hard edges that
we encountered, like Google
deployed the OAuth 1.0 at
scale, and we found a
lot of hard edges.
And we definitely brought our
experience that was the same
with many of the other
participants in
the OAuth 2.0 effort.
TIM BRAY: So I got one more
question here in the
moderator, and it's asking
about, could a slash-dot
well-known file published to
each provider's endpoint help
with interoperability?
This would describe their
implementation
response with JSON.
And we're talking
about discovery.
And it turns out that if I want
to do an OpenID Connect
interaction with Google or
Facebook or something, it
turns out that there are
three, four, at least,
different endpoints you
have to interact with.
There's the one for
authentication.
The one for getting a token.
There's user info.
There's at least three
I can think of.
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: Right.
TIM BRAY: Maybe more.
And so the fact that you know
you're going to Google.com or
Facebook.com doesn't actually
tell you enough.
So somehow, you need to find out
what those endpoints are.
Well, you can actually just
compile them into your code.
And if you're only dealing with
Facebook, Google, and
Microsoft, that's fine,
but that's kind of a
very limited world.
And we can imagine a world where
you would also like to
get identity from your bank or
your university or your state
government or whatever.
And so there's this notion
of discovery.
So there's another project
underway in the IETF called
Web Finger, which allows you to
give an email address to go
find out who their IDP is.
And there's another project
called Simple Web Discovery,
and there's some other work
in the OpenID Connect.
And so the answer to the
question is yes.
That's a good thing.
But I don't think those
protocols are
quite cooked yet.
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: Right.
And even Account Chooser is a
little entry point to start
discovering information about
the user, for instance, their
identity provider.
And so you can see that once all
these bits are together,
we're going to get more mileage
with identity with a
broader set of providers, maybe
as an out of the box
experience for developers.
TIM BRAY: OK.
Well, I think we've
about run through.
Any more voice of the internet
questions out there?
OK, folks.
Thanks everybody
for showing up.
Let's all remember the internet
is a big, scary,
dangerous place, and let's
be careful with people's
passwords, and let's HTTPS
everywhere whenever we can.
And let's do good security.
BRENO DE MEDEIROS:
That's right.
TIM BRAY: Thank you kindly.
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: Thank you.
TIM BRAY: And goodbye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]